il ya quelques jours je vous présentais
en parler je vous montrais une première
prise en main de l'iphone et ceux de
2020 2 de l'iphone et ce trois on peut
l'appeler comme on veut on va l'appeler
tout simplement l'iphone est et l'iphone
est ce c'est celui là c'est un tout
petit smartphone alors je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez l'iphone et ce alors
ce qui était présenté sa troisième
génération c'était vraiment le côté un
peu old school on garde le design de
l'iphone 8 de l'iphone celle de l'iphone
6 d'iphone os connaissait d'avant alors
qu'on a vu arriver deux iphone avec
fayçal 10 avec une encoche beaucoup plus
grand avec plus ce design donc c'est
l'iphone à peu look and feel ancienne
génération mais qui va rendre service à
plusieurs pour quoi et bien parce que il
ya un tout petit design parce qu'il ya
un vrai parti pris et parce qu'en fait
il manquait ce produit dans la gamme
d'apple et notamment un produit pas cher
pas cher je mets des guillemets on parle
toujours d'une apple ça reste toujours
un certain budget mais la question c'est
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui en 2022 voire en
2023/2024 parce que cet iphone il va
rester pour durée minimum 2 ans est-ce
que cet iphone il est toujours
intéressant est ce qu'on a toujours
envie d'un format comme celui-là est est
ce que si on a toujours envie d'un
format comme celui là est ce qu'il faut
venir se positionner parce qu'il fait
des jolies promesses pour autant est-ce
qu'il détient s qui beaucoup oui ou pas
c'est ce qu'on va regarder
[Musique]
c'est sympa d iphone mais le truc c'est
que ça prend les traces de doigts mais
je vous raconte même pas comment donc
tout au long de la vidéo regardée et les
traces de doigts qui vont apparaître de
tous les côtés alors je vais pas passer
mon temps à passer un coup de chiffon
net dessus parce que forcément je lui
tiens un côté de l'autre et que je
passerais mon temps à faire ça sent la
vidéo vous permet donc voilà il faut
accepter les traces de doigts et si vous
ne voulez pas les traces de doigts ce
qui font venir faire c'est mettre une
coque de protection aujourd'hui vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
rhinochill pour venir protéger oui
protéger votre iphone et ceux de 2022 ou
iphone et ceux de troisième génération
et avec le code greu 22 vous avez -5%
sur tout le site de rhinau chine
regarder ajoute shareen auch il vous
avez plusieurs protections vous avez
notamment à revoir les solides suite
vous avez plus de 120 modèles
disponibles dont apple samsung xiaomi
google huawei one + dont notamment
l'iphone et ce trois qui se situe juste
ici mais vous avez également des coques
de protection pour vos airpod et
notamment pour les airs paul iii qui
sont arrivés il ya pas très longtemps
gardé les apple 3 sont juste là ils sont
totalement personnalisables avec toutes
les collaborations qu'on peut retrouver
ici sherin au chip et les collaborations
il y en a un paquet on entend juste
après et puis vous avez également les
clearcase qui sont des coques 100%
transparente et garantie anti
jaunissement personnalisable avec toutes
les collaborations vous allez pouvoir
retrouver ici sherine o'sheas pour les
iphone 12 les iphone 13 sauf les
versions mini et puis surtout chez
rhinochill vous avez des tonnes de
collaboration on y re customiser vos
différentes protections et ça c'est
vachement intéressant je vous en ai déjà
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup présentez
vous allez avoir marvel vous allez avoir
mohamed ali disney classics one piece y
aura du star wars harry potter france
rugby attaques des titans bref il y en a
des tonnes des tonnes des tonnes des
tonnes je vous invite à venir cliquer
sur le lien présent en bas dans la
description choisir la coque de
protection qui conviendra le mieux qui
vous ira le mieux et pourquoi pas venir
la personnaliser avec tous les design
personnalisable que vous allez retrouver
ici sherine o'shea des n'oubliez pas
avec le code grevin de grr 22 profiter
de - 5% de remise sur l'ensemble du site
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle et merci
à rhinau shield avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo la première chose c'est le format
alors ce format se trouve intéressant
pourquoi parce que moi j'utilise ça un
iphone 13 promax et l'iphone 13 pro mac
c'est regarder ainsi
vous le connaissez eh ben c'est ca c'est
un monstre c'est un mastodonte et
l'iphone 13 pro mac c'est un très joli
smartphones mais hyper gros moi
j'utilise le plus gros des iphone et là
je vous présente le plus petit des
iphone alors plus petit haut niveau la
taille des écrans après vous avez
l'iphone 13 min qui est aussi un poil
plus petit mike une encoche nombre on va
se parler vraiment de l'écran ici alors
le format il est vraiment différent de
celui là regardez regardez regardez pour
moi c'est sans appel et ça montre
vraiment un truc à se montre vraiment
l'intérêt parce que alors ça ça prend
beaucoup de place dans une poche soyons
soyons clairs là dessus ça ça n'en prend
quasiment pas et c'est truqué vraiment
intéressant c'est parce que je prends je
le mets dans ma poche et il disparaît
complètement il est complètement
complètement invisible qui est en cause
ce format il reste vraiment intéressante
pour ça parce que tout le monde ne veut
pas un grand téléphone parce que tout le
monde n'a pas besoin d'un grand écran
même si la tendance va au grand écran
pourquoi pas très tendance va au gaming
et que l'on veut des grands écrans en
vue du confort on va regarder des films
des séries on veut du confort de
visionnage mais tout le monde ne veut
pas un grand écran c'est pas vrai talent
peut-être pas la majorité des
utilisateurs mais y'en a plein et c'est
pour ça que cet iphone reste aujourd'hui
intéressant ne serait ce qu'au travers
de ce format alors après il ya un autre
truc que ce format nous apprend c'est
qu'il est extrêmement fin alors qu'est
ce qui fait souvent l'épaisseur d'un
smartphone d'un iphone d'un boom du ray
hé bien ce sont les composants et quel
est le composant qui prend le plus de
place eh bien c'est la batterie et c'est
là où apple est vachement malin et
intéressantes à dire que je regarde l
épaisseur du truc vous le voyez il n'est
pas du tout et pc via que vous avez une
toute petite batterie alors à priori on
doit avoir une batterie qui se situe aux
alentours des 2000 milliampères heures
ça serait un petit peu l'histoire alors
vous allez me dire sur le papier si vous
êtes habitué aux specs notamment du côté
d'android vous dirait de 2008 antérieur
et des cultes une autonomie de quoi de
20 minutes non j'exagère quand je dis ça
non on a une autonomie qui va être d'une
bonne journée une bonne journée après ça
dépend des fois plus d usage allez pense
que vous allez en faire voir monter un
peu plus mais on n'a pas une très grosse
autonomie alors attention aux molières
pondérer sa passe d'ailleurs vous avez
la puce à 15 bionics est la même que
dans les fon 13 promax qui va apporter
beaucoup de performances et au delà de
la performance dans le calcul dans les
jeux et compagnie elle va venir
améliorer l'autonomie de par la finesse
de gravure et de par la capacité de
calcul est globalement c'est un petit
peu ça donc ça va venir emmené
l'autonomie un poil plus loin mais voilà
on baise basé sur un truc comme une
journée allez une bonne journée on va se
dire ça comme ça pour rester tranquille
l'autre truc qu'il faut savoir ici c'est
que votre iphone vous n'avez pas de bloc
de charges incluent voilà ci soit pas de
bloc de charges que vous voulez il faut
bien l'acheter en plus c'est un
smartphone que vous allez mettre du
temps à recharger bien vous ayez une
petite batterie donc il va falloir
s'armer de patience et en plus vous avez
de la recharge sans fil ce qui peut être
plutôt pas mal ça si ça vous intéresse
donc on a un format qui est très compact
qui est très pratique on voit que ce
format il est tout mini est pas très
épais 2 par le fait qu'on a une toute
petite batterie à l'intérieur c'est un
vrai choix vrai parti pris du côté
d'apple mais je dirais que le côté un
peu négatif de la petite autonomie vient
être contrebalancé par côté positif du
petit format maintenant notre question
qui vient se poser ici c'est la question
de l'écran parce que ouais on a vraiment
un écran qui est petit tout petit mais
moi une fois de plus qu'il suis habitué
à avoir un très grand écran comme ça ça
me perturbe un peu mais parce que je
suis habitué parce que j'ai un très gros
iphone si toutefois je n'étais pas
habitué ça me dérangerait moi ce que je
fais naturellement je prends et je le
rapproche de ma vue et là je me rends
compte que j'ai 42 ans qui forge le
recul si vous avez mon âge vous
comprenez la blague donc en fait c'est
assez marrant le truc parce que y'a un
côté un peu perturbant à avoir un écran
plus petit canton habitue un très grand
écran mais pour autant ça fonctionne je
peux pas vous dire que ça fonctionne pas
ça fonctionne vraiment donc je le mets
toujours en parallèle avec l'iphone que
j'utilise tous les jours qui est
monstrueux si on met en face d'un iphone
13 min ou d'un iphone 13 paraîtra moins
déconnant c'est une certitude les icônes
me paraissent fatalement plus petit
parce qu'elles le sont parce que j'ai un
écran beaucoup plus petit n'oublions pas
qu'ici j'ai une dalle de 4,7 pouces
alors j'aurais aimé avoir un écran
mollet ce qui n'est pas le cas ici apple
nous a laissé un écran lcd j'aurais aimé
avoir du full hd plus ce qui n'est pas
le cas ici j'ai un écran hd pour autant
et c'est là où un peu les forces cet
écran est vachement bien calibré il est
extrêmement qualitatif donc je veux dire
beaucoup une fois de plus mais c'est
vrai que cet iphone ne s'adresse pas
tout il s'adresse pas aux personnes qui
veulent des smartphones avec un confort
de visionnage il s'adresse aux personnes
qui veulent un iphone tout petit format
mais qui veulent un iphone n'est qu'ils
ne veulent pas un endroit parce qu'on
peu trop les androïdes plus petit que ce
soit chez asus que ce soit d'un autre
constructeur mais ici on va là c'est
qu'on veut à ios et on veut en plus de
la performance parce qu'ici vous avez
beaucoup de performances avec derrière
puces à 15 bionique vous pourrez faire
tourner tous les derniers jeux de
l'appstore son problème vous avez
beaucoup de performance et ça il faut le
savoir donc ya pas de compromis qui fait
là dessus donc c'est un iphone qui n'a
rien à envier aux performances à
l'iphone 13 promax que j'utilise moi au
quotidien et le fait d'avoir cette puce
ça vous apporte autre chose ça vous
apporte pour la première fois sur un
iphone est ce et bien de la 5g alors si
vous voulez de la 5g pour avoir une
connexion extrêmement rapide pour avoir
des latence très faible et bien vous
pouvez la mort avec cet iphone est ce ça
aussi c'est vachement bien là maintenant
il ya un autre truc qui revient quand on
le voit effectivement au delà du look au
delà des grandes bordure en haut et en
bas c'est le fait de se dire on n'a pas
fait que saïdi effet saïdi ces pratiques
alors la limite de fait samedi elle a
été un petit peu vu au début du coc vie
parce que même pendant les trois quarts
du coc vide parce que vous ne pouviez
pas à déverrouiller votre smartphone
avec un masque alors aujourd'hui les
masques tombent aujourd'hui une mise à
jour sur ios 15.4 qui vous permet de
déverrouiller avec un masque sans apple
washam on pouvait le faire directement
de votre apple ou h au foyer dont
quelque part fait ça il a fallu du temps
mais fait ça il dit permet avec un
masque et bien d'utiliser son iphone
très facilement mais pour tous ceux qui
n'avaient pas fait saïdi et qui utilisé
un iphone et ceux de deuxième génération
ou deux premières générations dans des
vieux iphone 2 août est content de
retrouver touch heidi alors top ça il
dit c'est très pratique pourquoi parce
que c'est capteur d'empreintes digitales
qui vous permet de déverrouiller votre
iphone très facilement vous posez votre
doigt hop là vous appuyer sa
déverrouille il ya un côté expérientiel
qui est un petit peu différent qui est
un peu moins sexy que saïdi et que
certaines personnes vont aimer alors je
sais pas si c'est votre cas moi je me
dis je donne l'impression sur iphone
c'est quand même un peu old school ainsi
des touch il dit mais pour autant
regarder il vous le met la même sur un
iphone sorti en 2022 dont bon j'ai envie
de dire pourquoi pas mais c'est vrai que
d'un point de vue purement esthétique je
trouve très anciens vraiment je me sens
que son iphone qui appartient au passé
je comprends que des gens qui désirent
un iphone petit nas et qui s'intéresse
pas du tout qu'ils s'en moquent de la
taille de l'écran et qui s'en moquent
d'abord tochigi donc si c'est votre cas
était pour vous d'ailleurs s'il vous
intéresse vous ai mis un lien badra
description il ya deux poids qui est
vachement intéressant c'est toute la
partie photo qu'on va pouvoir retrouver
avec cet unique capteur unique capteur
de 12 mégapixels alors autant la
configuration a pas bien changé 1 par
rapport à ce qu'on avait là sur les
générations précédentes un capteur de 12
mégapixels tout vrai 30.8 ça changé par
contre derrière c'est la puce l'a15
bionique va aller beaucoup plus loin va
aller beaucoup plus vite et va apporter
des choses vraiment intéressantes au
niveau de la photographie
computationnelle c'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui l'avenir optimiser vos
photos ça c'est vachement bien le
regarder je vous montre un peu on n'est
pas à la hauteur 1 très clairement de ce
conte avec l'iphone 13 promat iphone
très et compagnie mais on a fait ce que
son père mais plutôt pas mal alors la
partie quand même pas terrible terrible
on voit bien le ciel on à la face à bref
c'est clair alors je me suis permis de
venir ou mais normalement on vire passe
ou ne va pas de tels objectifs salon
vient pincer l'écran pour nous mais
c'était histoire de voir mes fois tout
de suite ça dégrade la qualité on a dû
dessus donc on va venir éviter la caméra
de seule fille est pas mauvaise je
trouve qu'elle fait le taff les teintes
de peau sont assez justes c'est plutôt
pas mal alors ici aucune stabilisation
optique donc bon mais malgré tout le
boulot est somme toute assez correct
alors là je suis venu chercher quelques
petites photos avec un petit contre jour
ici au niveau du ciel tout de suite il a
beaucoup plus du mal à venir gérer ses
hautes lumières là qui sont un petit peu
cramé pour autant on voit bien à la
façade du bâtiment delà du détail donc
c'est pas trop mal ça fonctionnera
lorsque je suis bien je vous met
également à envoyer ça ça fonctionne
plus il ya du bruit c'est pas beau ça
marche pas du tout l'appareil j'avais un
petit peu trop de soleil par là il a eu
un petit peu de mal au travers des
feuillages mais sinon le reste de la
photo est somme toute vraiment correct
donc ça conviendra light le ciel ça va
et si c'est tout sombre mais bon si ça
me ça me surprend pas et ça fonctionne
on voit bien la façade du bâtiment ici
qui est pas cramé pour le coup donc ça
ça marche aussi ça me va bien ces trucs
j'ai trouvé ma rente mise à part la
poubelle sur la gauche il ya un peu
dégueu français confirme à potton est
bon qu'on voit bien la façade du
bâtiment enfants claire mais pas trop
cramé ça va on est bien le tracé de
soleil là c'est pas cramé donc m une
gestion qui est correct ici au niveau
des hautes lumières donc ça fonctionne
on voit bien pour autant les hommes qui
vont être un peu plus sombre donc ça me
paraît pas déconnant j'ai tenté
également un zoom est vraiment c'est à
oublier on va bien vous ne regardez tout
de suite c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment pas beau là également le côté
un peu pénombre soleil pour voir comment
il gérait ça ils le gèrent pas trop mal
vraiment il ne gère pas trop mal donc ça
ça fonctionne bien il a mis c'est une
petite photo de bâtiments et bien je
trouve que c'est pas mal dans l'ensemble
plutôt pas mal il moi ce que vous en
pensez d'ailleurs en bas en commentaire
une autre photo également en valais avec
tous des partis qui sont un peu plus
exposé d'autres qui le sont beaucoup
moins mais pour autant on voit plutôt
toute façon correcte pas de problème
d'expos et si d'un côté l'autre la
voyait regardez là c'est pareil on
pourrait dire ça c'est un peu plus
compliqué si maintenant on regarde et on
a quand même bien les tuiles donc ça
fonctionne en qui son sens quand même
plutôt bien dans l'ensemble ajoute que
le travail est vraiment bien fait alors
là il ya eu beaucoup de soleil donc
forcément ça marche mieux mais je trouve
que les photos sont quand même plutôt
corps avec plutôt bien faites marche
plutôt bien là sur le contre jour on lit
quand même métropolitain même s'il a un
peu plus de mal à que soleil en pleine
tronche mais malgré tout on lit donc
c'est là où on voit le côté intelligence
artificielle qui viens vous apporter ça
et sur l'autre façade avec le soleil
forcément on lira également essayé de
suite beaucoup mieux alors les photos en
faible luminosité il s'en sort pas trop
mal grâce à tout ce travail qui est fait
au niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
mais on voit quand même que ici voyez eh
bien on a un peu de boulot de taz au
niveau de la façade et c'est un peu
moins bon que ce qu'on pourrait
retrouver avec un iphone outre un iphone
beaucoup plus actuelle pas là ici au
niveau de lumière voyez on assez petit
halo tour qui nous permettent de voir
qu'on n'est pas non plus sur les
derniers capteurs ça c'est une évidence
absolue mais malgré tout ce soir quand
même je trouve dans le fond plutôt bien
et pour un smartphone dans cette gamme
de prix pour un iphone dans cette gamme
de prix je veux dire que des grandes
guillemets ça marche il a eu un peu de
mal au niveau des hautes lumières ici
c'est là où on voit que c'est un iphone
13 car on voit la différence on la voit
vraiment de ce côté là voyez là c'est
pareil on a dû bruit ici là qui nous
montrent que c'est pas mal mais bon
voilà c'est pas non plus extraordinaire
pour autant apple n'est pas allé à
l'économie sur reste des techno on a du
wifi s'ils sont une certification ip67
on a bien évidemment ça je vous le dis
de la charge sans fil vous a bien
évidemment du nfc pour apple paye c'est
la moindre des choses on a une nano
symplus unis estime si vous voulez de la
double sim bouhenia film et chante et de
qu'à 60 images par seconde bref on a un
iphone qui même si il a un côté un peu
old school est loin de l'être au niveau
des techno qui surtout on le voit
vraiment le choix qu'a fait apple
l'assumé c'est pas la première fois nous
mettre la dernière puce directement dans
ce smartphone donc c'est un smartphone
même s'il a un côté un peu old school
comme ça même si on a un écran lcd avec
une résolution hd et bien on a de la 5g
on a du wifi si son un truc qui marche
bien on un très beau smartphone très fin
voilà donc il sera pas fait pour tout le
monde cette iphone et ce trois iphone
est ce 2022 il sera fait pour toutes les
personnes qui veulent un petit format un
iphone déjà un iphone très clairement
petit format un iphone pas du tout été
un iphone très fin qui se glisse partout
et qui s'en fiche d'avoir un très grand
écran pour regarder des films des séries
qui veulent pouvoir jouer de temps en
temps si long parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
de performances et qui veulent un
smartphone qui sera un peu passe partout
c'est vraiment l'idée alors attention
aux urnes le tarif si vous avez trois
config la version avec 64 go de stockage
on est à 5 129 euros la version avec 128
go de stockage on est à 579 euros et la
version 256 go de stockage on est à 699
euros et la version que je vous
recommande ici moi c'est la version 128
go de stockage à 579 euros pourquoi
parce que bien que ce soit un tout petit
iphone est très fort en vue de remettre
beaucoup de dents et si vous voulez pas
vous retrouver limiter un moment en
termes de capacité de stockage pour
mettre des films des séries des musiques
et compagnie et bien autant prévient
tout de suite un petit peu plus alors je
suis d'accord ça fait rajouter au niveau
du tarif ça fait m 50 euros de plus mais
vous le regrettez pas dans le temps vous
serez pas déçus donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant donc cet iphone je trouve
plutôt pas mal il sera plutôt pas
mauvais au niveau de la photo nous
donnera des résultats qu'ils sont
vraiment convenable équilibré alors on
n'ira pas aussi loin que ce qu'on peut
avoir avec un iphone 13 ou un iphone 13
pronation de 13 pro mac web iphone 13
min mais pour autant ce qu'il fait il le
fait plutôt pas mal je trouve qu orange
trouve convenable permet de faire
rentrer les iphone et sedan de la 5g hop
là tu dis oui quand tu veux donc voilà
alors après il est parfait pour moi
clairement moi j'irais pas dessus mais
peut-être que vous vous seriez dessus et
si vous regardez cette vidéo c'était
parce qu'il vous intéresse d'ailleurs
des clés mois en bas en commentaire et
n'oubliez pas s'il vous box vous amis
tous les liens juste en bas dans la
description dont on retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler taille parce
qu'à plein de choses qui arrivent plein
de nouveautés plein de smartphones et ça
c'est vachement bien alors je vous
embrasse pour lé soin de vous et
attrayant
mais